[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing fantastic beasts
3. more specifically we're going to be
taking a look at a leaked photo from
earlier this month
that gives us a tiny bit of insight into
the new film
with the film being pushed back and back
we really haven't
been given much the fans have been left
in the dark
so this photo leak however small is
quite exciting
at least to me the photo shown here
shows a room with architecture a bit
different than what we're used to
as it turns out the room is confirmed to
be in germany
but we don't have any more information
than that this does
however open up a whole bunch of
possibilities for where
and what this room is is it room inside
of the german ministry of magic
or could it perhaps be the home of gelat
grindelwald
some fans who commented on mugglenet's
instagram
who posted the photo have theorized the
latter
and i think that is a good guess
reliable sources who informed mugglenet
about the nature of the photo
have stated that the roman question is
the work of hitler's
personal architect albert speer who
inspired the designs in a leaked photo
spear was member of the nazi party from
1931 onwards
and quickly rose to prominence in
hitler's inner circle as a result of his
architectural prowess
allegedly the inspiration from spear in
this backdrop
is meant to be obvious and this all
checks out given that the fantastic
beasts franchise
is known to take place in germany to
some extent during the second world war
while this photo just gives us a taste
of the films to come
hopefully warner brothers can roll out
some more information on the film in the
coming months
perhaps even a teaser trailer what do
you guys think of this photo
is it the german ministry of magic a
room from grindelwald's mana
or something else altogether comment
down below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe
to the channel until next time it does
not do to dwell on dreams
forget to live